like everybody here we can all consume
whatever we want so we can find whatever
planes we like you know you can fly
private you can stay in the nicest
hotels get the nicest airbnbs go out to
dinner every single night of the week at
the five-star restaurant at the Michelin
star
and you can do that for the rest of your
life like you your personal needs as a
human being are satisfied but I can't
get by that skyscraper right there
and I can't buy this huge company and so
what happens is like the things that you
want to buy change and so you create a
new deficit for the amount of wealth
that you want again this is just
assuming you like the game and so like I
like the game and so I just want to keep
playing it
[Music]
where should we where should we start
because you do a lot of these interviews
what uh what's the fun version of this
for you because I feel like if somebody
actually wants to know an answer to
something it's been published you got a
book you got a Twitter you got it you
got a thousand YouTube videos like if
you're motivated you can go find the
answer like I tweeted out yo Alex coming
on the Pate what would you like to know
they're like I'd like to know his
thoughts on offers making a cheaper
offers like that's literally his book
and I think the book is like free or 99
Cents so like that's just a lazy lazy
question at this point
um but I know whenever I do interviews
there's some version of the
conversations that are more fun or I'm
like yeah when we talk about that stuff
it's more interesting to me and that
kind of Lights me up in a different way
what is that for you well I'll say
there's two things that I've been um
probably focused a lot on one is uh
obviously acquisition.com and so like
what we're doing and
um kind of clarifying the mission
between
well all the stuff that we're actually
doing every day
um and then the other side of it is just
that the leads book is coming out and so
it's tough because I'm sure you guys
have had stuff that you've worked on and
uh it's like been on its way coming out
and all of your energy is going into
writing it or building it or recording
stuff about it and then you can't talk
about it because I don't wanna I don't
wanna I don't want to talk about it all
the time until it's like ready to to go
off and so the six weeks beforehand is
when it's like we have all this
pre-recorded stuff I've got like full
courses like I've got all this [__]
that's gonna that's gonna drop
um when the next book comes out but I
haven't talked about anything leads
related for like two years because I've
known because I've been working on it
for two years uh for the next launch so
those are the two things
um that are like top of mind for me like
what we're doing on the most immediate
side and acquisition.com and then
and then the weed stuff what's the split
between those two so you got media you
got acquisitions.com give me the time
split so given on a given month you know
what percent if there's a pie chart what
do you spending on on the content versus
Acquisitions and then also on the money
side like uh are you making more off the
media or are you making more off
Acquisitions what's this what's the
relative difference between the two yeah
we we lose money on media
um so no we we don't make money I think
I think between like AdSense and if you
consider Book Sales a part of that
um but I give the book away for 99 cents
actually Amazon updated it because we
re-uploaded it with like some fix hits
and they wouldn't let us go below one
night which now makes all the times I
said 99 Cents like people were like
Jesus trying to get us it sucks anyways
um but no I think the book does
um
the book says about a million bucks a
year in profit in terms of like what it
what it makes
um and then and then AdSense is probably
like 500 Grand a year so it's like one
and a half million and that that barely
covers the media team uh and so that's
how big is the team right now we've got
10 and then we've got vendors are you
enjoying it
yeah I dig it it's fine right now we do
I look forward once said to answer your
question Sean about time split uh we do
one recording day every 14 days that's
like the direct to camera stuff and then
here you go off I do a podcast like I
got one of my guys here Trevor um who's
reporting you know our our side of it so
that they can clip this stuff later so
are you enjoying like the celebrity that
comes with this you know getting noticed
and things like that
um enjoys probably like because I feel
like there's some people who love
attention and there's some people who
hate attention I'm like
right in the middle you know what I mean
like I was I was purposely deliberately
not public because I wanted to be rich
and Anonymous and that was kind of like
the mission for a long time for me
um and then now that we are on there I
would say that there are pros and there
are cons of increasing you know fame or
what do you want to call it recognition
um
I think the pros outweigh the cons but
there are cons like what
uh you get weirdos you know I mean like
we have we have security you know I mean
like we go to like I can't I can't
attend any of it
like I can't attend a vet like I can't
go to somebody's like small group Meetup
like I can't like it's it's very hard uh
because I can't enjoy anything uh
because I'll have a line of people who
are you know asking for advice or
signatures or pictures or whatever and
like again I am grateful as [__] to
everybody to do that it's just like it's
a different experience so I just have to
I have to if I'm gonna go to something I
go into it knowing that's what my
experience is going to be not whatever
or whoever's on stage
yeah but it's the online experience dope
but it makes the real life experience
less different it's different that's
what it fundamentally just changes with
the in-person experience it's like if I
walk out so like what's interesting is
that I was able to or I have been able
to to to Mark how social media and like
the the audience has grown by the number
of real world interventions I had per
unit of time and so like I remember the
first time I recognized public and then
it was once a month and it was once a
week and then it was once a day and then
it was every time I'd walk outside the
door and now it's about five times or
six times every time I walk outside
um I get I get recognized
um and so like I just imagine that that
just continues to compound you know with
time and with distribution so it's just
it's different but here's the pros we
get the best talent for our portfolio
companies and for acquisition.com
because so many people want to come here
um we get them for at market rate or or
below because of all the learnings that
they want and the other people who are
also Pro players on the team uh we get
the best deal flow that's all
proprietary companies that want to work
specifically with us they're not trying
to exit to anyone or sell to anyone they
want to work with us deliberately to
scale the company so like I continue to
do it because I'm more rewarded for
doing it than I am punished for doing it
but there are definitely you know you
get weird letters and you get you know
weird attacks and things like that like
it's just you know it's it comes with
the territory and it's to be expected
and so
um for us the pros outweigh the cons but
there are kinds I remember talking to uh
Tim Ferriss and you could just tell from
the outside but he I don't know if he's
mainstream famous or not uh or if I'm in
a bubble but he's popular enough that he
has all these people listening to him
and all that stuff but he well the cool
thing about him was
he had high profile people and people
who like a lot of people who listen to
you you're like I'm thankful that you
listen but I don't exactly want to go
hang out with you but she would actually
have a ton of listeners who would reach
out to him who were like you know like
the Matthew mcconies of the world or or
some like football coach or Ryan holiday
has that too where it's like someone
who's like a big deal who you're like oh
my God you listen to me that's amazing I
would I would be honored to go and hang
out with you and he had he had stories
like that and Sean and I have had that a
little bit where like some like business
person who we both admire will be like
yeah I heard your pot on this thing and
I'm like oh wow you listen to that has
that have you crossed that threshold
where you have people who you admire who
are messaging you and being like man
what you said was really cool what's
your you know I have a question about X
Y and Z and you're like oh man that's
amazing My Heroes want to talk to me now
yeah
um I mean yes I don't want to put anyone
on blast but like there have been some
mega mega influencers who are like
followed me and like hit me and they're
like dude this is awesome and I'm like
well now I think less of you because you
follow my content so uh yeah big red
flag there yeah I told Layla the biggest
red flag I had with her was that she was
anyway
um
oh I'm not kidding but um but yeah like
some NFL players that I used to like you
know really look up to like huge MLB
stars like and uh like huge huge
podcasters that that you know followed
me and and uh yeah it's been cool one of
the one of the reverse situations is
when I like go to like see I'm like oh
yeah how is so and so celebrity and I
click and it says like follow back and
I'm like oh [__]
uh but no it's it's cool I mean it's
it's it's surreal I'm sure you guys have
it's surreal it's very um well I grew up
like admiring Lance Armstrong I'm big
into the Endurance Sports and one time I
got an email and it was like uh hey just
let you know I love the hustle
uh and he signed it with Lance and uh
you could tell it was Lance Armstrong by
his Gmail and I was like I don't believe
this is really Lance Armstrong if it is
here's my phone number call me right now
and he he called me within like three
minutes and I was like he called he goes
Sam what's going on and I was like Lance
is this really useful yeah
and I and then I had a couple other
athletes holler at us and I remember
thinking like growing up playing sports
I would have killed you had an athlete
like this recognized me and I could
never achieve the athletic greatness
enough for them to acknowledge you know
my talents and then now you just take
this total like outside path and you get
to it or like one time we had like this
was really weird but like the lead
singer of Linkin Park uh Mike he like
tweeted out that he likes our pod and
the hustle whatever and I was like oh
that's sick like I never I would have
wanted to have met you but there's no
way I could have gone down this normal
path but if we went this weird way we
finally kind of met and I found that to
be very strange and awesome
yeah it's sort of that uh be so good
they can't ignore you as a general
advice for Life uh like whatever you
want is on the other side of you being
so good that you can't be ignored at
anything and and anything and also
um like it doesn't have to be I think
that's kind of what you're saying Sam it
doesn't have to be the thing you expect
right um like oh you want you know you
want to meet Warren Buffett someday you
don't have to be a stock picker that's
not that's probably actually the least
likely way that Warren Buffett's going
to want to gonna want to know you and in
general you shouldn't really pick based
on what they want you should just pick
based on the thing you can actually get
so good at that you can't be ignored and
uh it's hard to do obviously that's hard
to do but it's like more of the it's
more of the right guidance than uh than
many other bits of advice you could take
as far as like a North star for how
you're gonna like you know what you're
gonna go for
right exactly
um and so anyway it's cool that we're
all kind of like seeing that in reality
uh it doesn't come true Alex uh go ahead
sorry go ahead Sam I was gonna say are
you enjoying acquisitions.com because I
know when we first talked to you I think
you're maybe only a year or two years in
you're relatively new I think you had
just sold
um gym launch are you happy with like uh
is it what you thought it was going to
be and do you actually like do it and by
the way explain what Acquisitions yeah
what that is yeah so it's
acquisition.com the reason I I emphasize
that is because there's somebody about
Acquisitions plural.com and it's just
not it's not me it's different from me
but acquisition.com
um is our portfolio companies and uh
so I'll give the the tldr 90 seconds so
I uh had a chain of jams took that
license the IP to 5000 locations started
supplement Company sell through that
distribution base and then started a
software company we exited all three of
those companies in 2021 uh we taken out
40 million in distributions prior to the
exit we sold for 46.2 million and the
software company I did separately or
sold separately in a strategic deal that
was all stock
um and I I said that because you guys
would probably laugh because like I I
were like I Googled drama's net worth
and it says 15 million it's like well I
sold the company for 46 and all cash so
like I don't know where you got that and
the only reason you do that and get that
money is because it was making money so
so anyways
um that was pretty much 2021 so we
closed December 25th
or sixth I can't remember it was it was
one of those days it was right around
it's showing A4 it's Christmas Eve
that's twice Christmas Eve we is we
closed
um and then we started acquisition.com
the next day uh and so that was when we
like Oakley made our kind of Declaration
at that point though it already made
three uh minority Investments uh that
had done really really well and that's
why I wanted to make that kind of my
next big thing if you started it the
next day that means you kind of had this
idea cooking so what was the what was
the Genesis why did you why do what made
you realize oh this is what I should do
next I should buy these minority stakes
and companies like the one I just built
and I should get this domain name uh
which I assume you had to buy so how
were you so ready to do that what was
the thought process
so
um during covid guys obviously gyms were
affected by covid uh you know we took a
hit right we took a major hit we were so
profitable but it was a it was a big you
know it was hard
um and so to kind of get some space
because there wasn't a lot like
do more you know there was gonna be like
obviously we you know we pushed things
harder but like I was on above the
business enough that there was nothing I
was I was gonna do anything right
um and so I kind of just needed to take
my my mind off things and so by by
happenstance uh a guy who owned a
photography a single photographer studio
um made his movie on my calendar and in
the first and this is not how you do
this everyone like do not do this uh but
I was actually still taking some calls
for Alan because I wanted to do some
like testing and this is before I had a
big brand so I was just kind of like
found her talking to customers to get an
idea of what was going on but he knew me
enough from just like I had written a
small book in the gym space called Jim
Lodge secrets that he had read that book
like love did applied it to his
photography business and she took a
sales call through my software company
because he knew I was taking the calls
and so he hopped on and was like I had
no interest in your software he's like
but can you please give me 20 minutes
and I was like sure man all right I just
like this Vibe and so anyways we ended
up doing a deal uh and so we took
minority percentage of the business and
that business I think had done
1.6 they're doing 1.6 million a year at
a single single location uh which is
pretty awesome for a tiny like
photography studio and he I think he had
taken and this isn't all the book
clearly because there's a million thing
but he taken some of the concepts from
General Shaker's book applied them and
it had grown the business a lot and he
had an agency uh for photographers to
kind of like do the same model for them
right and so we were having a
conversation
um and he was like yeah I did exactly
what you said and all the photographer
Studios add 400 000 a year uh to Top
Line uh when they use our thing I was
like they add 400 000 a year he's like
yeah on average it was like
okay uh how much are we selling this
thing for and I used these like pennies
and I was like okay so um let's not do
that and uh let's own them all
and so that kind of pit so he actually
and this is where like the the trust
factor of what like the inbound deal
coach is what I love about
activision.com is that we have a lot of
trust and so we actually shut down a
business that was making him I think 500
000 a year in profit uh that agency side
and shut it down to zero uh um because
he like believed that he believed me
enough to to go all in on this other
direction of private ownership of all
the locations and so um as of today that
was 2020 as of today we have 36
locations uh in that business you know
just 30 plus million a year uh and it
continues to grow back at one or two
locations every month and so what's
what's that business do interesting it
varies so it's children's photography
right dude that's insane and you so when
when we last had you on I saw I went to
the website and I was like okay cool
what what are the Acquisitions great
what are the what they acquire and I saw
basically like uh enchanted fairies and
I was like okay cool they're doing like
the gym launch Playbook on this other
space that makes a lot of sense and if I
go there today they're still the same
company so how come you're not putting
new acquisitions up there uh I assume
you've made a bunch of Acquisitions like
you know in the last 24 months or
whatever uh why not put new companies
out there you're pretty open about other
stuff but in this case you're not
putting them up there and then also uh
let's start with that yeah main reason
so there's two big reasons why we're not
public uh the Acquisitions
um number one is that
it's my brand has grown to such a degree
that like if I say hey this business is
awesome and it and it has a national
ability like enchanted fairies is less
of it you know like unless you're in one
of those 30 markets and also my audience
isn't like moms with kids so like it's
it's it's you know it's it's arm's
length enough that it doesn't affect the
business but as you can imagine a lot of
the businesses come to me are business
services and uh they're you know their
National their International whatever
companies and so like me endorsing a
company with five 10x the company
overnight and so that comes with a
couple things one is that I haven't
negotiated those deals with a brand
endorsement included if I include a
brand endorsement then I own majority
I'm not gonna like I'm not gonna risk my
face
on something I can't control
and so these are most of them most of
the Investments we have are minority we
do have a majority of investment as well
um but that was one that came in as a
minority and then I just bought more of
excel of the business
um
and it was up our wheelhouse
the second thing is that if we were to
exit those businesses and I had done an
endorsement in a minority position then
guess who has to go with the deal me
right like I would as an acquirer if
there's some massive influencer that's
associated with the brand like he's not
getting out in a deal and so our role
goal is to build value in the in the
business so that the business is
sellable and more valuable
um and we use my face to bring deals in
and so that's why I've been really
really tight-lipped about
um the businesses how many deals have
you done so far we've done right now we
have 11 portfolio companies is it all
your own money or you raised a fund no
it's all private it's online
damn dude so you're you're going all in
on this and so I asked you originally
are you happy with how this is working
out is it what you thought it was what's
he gonna say no
well yeah I could be like well he's like
well I didn't realize like uh this is
actually just some mostly a due
diligence game
um and yeah I don't know I mean what's
the worst part about it what's something
you didn't kind of what's a downside you
didn't fully respect up front so
I think there's like
knowing something and then experiencing
it are two kind of separate things and
so like I know that in a minority
position we have to use soft influence
to to to try and move things forward
um I know that but I would say that the
most difficult part is is is half
listened to advice
and so I'll give you an example so if I
say hey we think that this operator in
your business blows and we need a new
operator person says okay
and then we find the new operator and
then they hire the new operator but then
they don't fire the old operator
I put the [__] right right very hard
to win at that point right it's like
well I listen so like it's kind of like
listening to half of someone's diet
advice it's like yeah yeah I'm doing the
cheat days for rushing the cheat days
it's a gift but there's the other days
that you're in a deficit yeah but you
said cheat days raise your metabolism
like yeah but you also need a deficit
you know what I mean and so it's it's
it's listening and completeness and so
um I don't know we may move to like
because like the business that I I would
say transparently that I enjoy the most
is the one that we have complete control
of and so we bought majority of that
business and we were growing that one
like gangbusters and the speed to action
is so much faster
um that being said you know we've you
know I would say like the biggest wins
we have a company that came to us at 16
million uh the year before yeah you know
did 50 last year
um
uh so it's the biggest company that we
have in portfolio
um
we've had you know the enchanted various
is obviously one that you know that at
two-ish with you know combining the two
things they'll they're pacing two and a
half million a month right now or 2.7
something like that
um so we have some kind of a big
ridiculous deal right like I had a
friend message me that was like dude
hermosi's Playbook is uh obviously
amazing but he's like this deal that
they offered us he's like I don't know
who would take this and uh you know he's
like there's I don't know if this is
actually the deal or not but he's like
basically it was like no money we'll
give you no money but we get ownership
if we grow it above X so it's kind of
like uh I think sounded like more of a
risk risk-free strategy in a way but
um so is that is there a standard deal
structure and is that it where you're
not putting capital in you're basically
saying
give us the equity we guarantee we grow
by this much and if we don't some I
don't know some some clawback we've
iterated it honestly a bunch of times so
one of the one of the so this is a to
answer your question Sam like probably
even more poignantly now that we're
getting into it one of the hardest
things about like the investment cycle
is that when you're making a product
right you're trying to sell a service
you can ideate it create an MVP pitch it
see how it goes within like 60 days like
the whole like the whole thing Soup To
Nuts you can you can do that whole cycle
60 days for deals it's like you can
think of in a you know an idea for a
deal structure it takes 90 days to six
months to close the deal and then it
might take a year to see even just like
some preliminaries of like how do we
like this structure how does it work etc
and so like I still feel like we are
most in our infancy in the deal
structures that we have so like uh in
terms of no money in there are deals we
put money in there are deals that we
don't put money in it depends on the
deal
um like the big one for money is it
depends on what the need of the business
is so like if we're opening up a lot of
brick and mortar locations like we're
about to I think we might have actually
closed today tomorrow uh on a 28 uh
location chain
um that one requires Capital to open
more locations so that one like I know
where the capital is going I see what
their turns on capital r let's get that
right if it's a National based service
business so let's say it's uh you know
mortgage sales like they don't need
there's no capex like they just need
recruiting guys right that's how that's
how sales gets increased and so like
that's where that's where where does the
money like where's the money going and
what is it used for like what I don't
want to do is just like someone got to
go buy a mansion after I write a check
like that's not the goal here like the
goal is that we're both together wanting
to grow this massive thing
um and so it just really depends on on
what the what the negative to the deal
is so that's number one
um in terms of uh how we structure them
uh originally I had a grand slam offer
type thing now it's just much more
straightforward like we were you know
we're Equity holders in the business
it's interesting because it's actually
gotten less cute and less clever as time
has gone on like it's just much more
like
this is our deal like we own a big chunk
of the business
um and we're gonna grow it and I mean
the thing is is that for us based on my
hold go boss like I put 500 000 a year
in labor into the businesses
and like that's if I wanted to like not
mark up labor like that's hard cost and
so if a company for example uh you know
is doing whatever
five million a year in ebitda and I'm
and I'm buying a you know a one-third
steak or a 40 stake in the business like
how like what am I valued at and how
much of that value is going to come in
the for in the form of of just work that
we're gonna do and so that's where
that's where the valuation and how much
cash in ETC kind of becomes more like a
deal uh basis but yeah so the all extra
shirt is one is soft influence has been
something that I've been learning we may
in the future just do more majority
deals
um where the founder stays on because
like what I want to do is show how much
more we grew this oh I mean we do have
obviously some minority ones that have
crashed too but like I I want to murder
this maturity deal and be like wouldn't
you like to have 49 of something 10
times bigger or 100 times bigger uh
and so that's kind of the the angle but
yeah we're learning every day we talked
to uh our good friend is Andrew
Wilkinson and he's done a similar-ish
thing as you and then
um we've got a handful of other friends
that have done something and they're
like well I got really inspired when I
read uh the Swarm Buffett book uh and
that like taught me a little bit about
compounding growth uh and now that
people have cited other books or things
that they learned where they're like oh
no this is the way to go and that's what
I that's why I got into this what about
you what what transitions you from going
to this like almost PE model versus just
one brand model
yeah you know definitely if I were to if
I were to give us a a name it would be
like a merger of a family office and a
conglomerate uh because family in the
office in that it's literally just
family money like I don't I don't have
any outside investors and then
conglomerate in terms of like our
business model like I'm not trying to
exit anything I would like to continue
to compound the Investments we have if a
Founder absolutely like needs to or
wants to or you know gets divorced and
ask them to create the asset then like
we will go down that that route that
long-term long-term holders
um but in terms of the inspiration
um it was actually because gym launch
has there's only 50 000 microchips like
in the US at least and we had already
got on the phone with 20 000.
so like if you're a micro gym owner know
who you are probably and I realized I
went to this um this little Meetup of
entrepreneurs and it was like six or
seven people and the whole room was
doing in aggregate like 500 million a
year in Revenue
and I was you know I think we were doing
like mid 30s at the time and uh
I was like I I was really excited to go
because I was like what do these guys
have that I don't have like I wanted to
you know like what am I missing right
and we had been there for like three
years we've been in the mid 30s for
three years I felt like I was like
something was wrong
and the big takeaway I had was not that
they had better systems or they're
better marketing or better sales or a
better product they just were going
after you know where like every single
one of them two men had a market that
was 10 to 100 times the size
and so I said that whatever I wanted to
do next was going to be was going to go
after a much bigger bar and there are
significantly more businesses than there
are James uh and so that was kind of the
big thing it's like okay well it's
something that can compound forever and
that has a huge town
and so we kind of like walked backwards
from there and then in terms of like the
the doing this model like we believe
that people like build the people and
the people who build the business and so
like Layla you know when we were it was
like 18 months of ideation I know we're
going full circle but like how did we
start the next day
well these are the things that we're
thinking through
um and I said Layla if I were to die
tomorrow what business would you start
she was like I would start a recruiting
firm you know like I don't want to start
a recruiting firm I was like huh I want
like is there a way that we could
combine what you like and what I like
into something cool and so for us like
the most Hands-On valuable thing that
you can do for a business is find a
players because if you find a players
you put them in the business and they
grow the business and then that value
stays inside the Enterprise of the
business not Old Co like not the goose
but the egg right and so for us we just
recruit crazy talent because we like our
competitive mode is that we have more
influence than they do and so we have a
whole culture community of Mosey Talent
where our head of people like continues
to bring like we have tons of people
every single day that are applying for
portfolio positions and then we can
screen them vet them and then because we
know the company and because we're
long-term incentivized we don't just
want to like put a body in a seat we
want to find the killer that we know
that if we that we we don't want to fill
the role once right we want to fill up
with somebody who matches the culture
and matches the skill set of the
business at this level so a lot of times
like first-time entrepreneurs they're at
whatever a million months and they're
like okay do I hire a bookkeeper do I
hire a staff accountant do I hire a
controller do I hire a CFO do I hire
Director of Finance like where like who
am I hiring right now and what does that
person look like and so like we've done
this enough times to be like okay at
this level you probably need a
controller who has experience going from
a million a month to three million a
month and right and like at that point
they and we'll tell them up front that
we will bring a CFO a transaction
experience in the future so they're not
jostled when that happens right same
thing they're scaling out the sales team
they're like okay well I've got three
good guys it's like cool we need 20. so
like you can't just take your best
closer and make a manager because he's
never done this before so we want
somebody who's built at least one or two
sales teams specific to let's say it's
inbound or might be all about it depends
on like the sale process of the business
and they've built those types of teams
and like cool we'll bring that guy in we
have our class books then we say hey on
our interview process we're like this is
how we do things during line with that
and if we do feel like there's alignment
and they can they have the chops because
we do skill tests then we can say hey I
think that you'll match and obviously
the founder still has final say because
they have to like the person the rice is
going to work um but we do a lot of that
heavy lifting because you know we might
take 100 interviews at holdco to find
one one guy for one specific role for
one company and that's where that labor
cost comes in for us but we'll actually
put like the reason we took majority
in a taken during black majority of the
uh of that business was we had built the
entire executive team
we built the entire executive team and
we're like okay cool and the fatter is
like you know what I kind of want to do
other things to the business like I know
it's in good hands I trust you guys and
so it was like a very friendly deal and
now he just gets checks every month
and like likes his life a lot and we
just continue to run the business which
we're cool there's this really cool
video where you're with Grant Cardone
and I think you're like in the process
or pre- uh process for selling gym
launch and you're like and he said
something like
rich people sell their companies wealthy
people never sell and it's cool is that
I've sold the company before Sean has
sold some companies before you've sold
the company what's so funny is a lot of
first-time Founders and second third
time maybe a lot of people their whole
business is selling but
after they sell they go through this
period and they're like [__] I shouldn't
sell ever again actually and you said
you sold the business for 47 million you
said you had taken 40 million in
distributions so in my head I'm like
that's a pretty [__] sale then do you
wish that you would have just held on to
it and and never sold that that company
no
because the person I was then wouldn't
be able to do what I can do
could I do that could I today would I
hold on to it yes
but I don't think I could have done it
then and so a lot of the reasons like
transparently if buy it I got more
credibility from selling gym launch at
46 and it was valued at 150 before cobit
so to your point it was a [__] sale
um but I was done I was emotionally done
with the business I just didn't want to
do it anymore I still own a third of the
business so like when they crushed the
exit the next exit at 250 million I'll
still get my 100 million dollar check
from that
um but I was
I was emotion I moved on and my big
thing is like all my friends all
Blacklist people were like dude you
sound depressed as far like you're not
interested and I was like dude I want to
do this new thing and they're like dude
you light up when you talk about this
new thing and so
um I actually walked away from the deal
during the deal process and then came
back uh and so like yeah it was not like
it's funny because people give me a lot
of I'm glad you brought it up because a
lot of people give me praise for that
but they don't have context like get
what like you know we had done we did 30
million in eBay the two the 24 months
prior to do the deal
so like you know selling a 46.2 is not
like like I I told them I needed to be
public about the number because I do
know that the vast majority of people
don't get it
um and that that is enough to give me
credibility for [__] Tick Tock
um but it's not like the transaction
itself isn't necessarily one that I'm
like proud of I'm proud of what we built
that's a Contin the company's run 40
since we sold it
um it's a they're gonna kill on that
deal but now that I also understand how
debt Works which I didn't understand
that like again this is like knowing
experiencing like I understood that they
were gonna get debt but when I realized
that
80 or 90 of the money that they put in
they then just immediately hold right
back out leveraging the company's books
I was like well [__] I could have kept
the whole [__] thing and gotten 90 of
the money not personally guaranteed and
de-risk myself
but with that created the same story of
something that is sellable from a
personal branded perspective and I think
the answer is no and so
um I don't regret the sale I think the
sale was required for that step in my
journey I think that now
because we have the credibility like no
one cared that I taking 40 million in
distributions I'm going to give a [__]
like it didn't matter like the day I
sold my neighbors were like oh I saw you
on Forbes like congratulations I was
like I was richer before I did the
transaction
I was well there before that boy
um but like it allowed us to do
acquisition on economics I don't think I
could have because my brand was still so
I was still the CEO as far as people
were concerned of that company and I
needed to have that space so that I
could create acquisition there
our software
's HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM our software is the best HubSpot
grow better
Sean would you have done what do you
think would you have done that I think
he explained it beautifully I think he
explained it exactly beautifully and
honestly which was that
two things you just said that I resonate
deeply with me one this is the last
thing you just said which is
to have what you want sometimes you just
need to make space and so this is like I
learned this through relationships
you're dating somebody you kind of
they're not exactly what you want
they're not bad there's nothing wrong
there's nothing terrible about it so
most people just stick with it for years
and years and years and then they're
kind of like well if there was like a
much better option then yeah like I
would feel more comfortable just like
going being single but I've always been
very quick to just if I know this isn't
it I'll break up I don't need to have
another great option ready uh or or like
shown to me to make it real I know that
if I make space then great things can
appear and sometimes you just gotta do
that like I've taken like when we sold
bibo it was the same thing I had
I've been doing this thing for six or
seven years and the business was doing
okay at that point and thought you know
but in my heart of hearts I knew this is
never going to be massive and we had all
gone into that business with the
basically like yo let's do something
massive so by other people's standards
it might have been a good business by
our our own mission it was going to be a
failure I knew that and so it was when I
was out with a friend and he was like I
don't get what you're doing and he's
like you just need to shake things up
and um you know I was shook I couldn't
sleep I was like he's right like I've
been doing this for too long I need to
shake things up and so I went into our
our investor the next day and I just
said um
I think it's time we change things up I
said I need to change things up I said
yeah you know if you want to keep going
uh I will help you hire a CEO and you
can take have somebody else take this
over I'll give you back my shares I
don't need a thing from this like I I
will do whatever I can or
give me 30 days I'm gonna see if I can
sell
or I'm out like those are the this is
either way in 30 days this is gonna
change for me I've just decided to make
space basically for something he's like
well what do you want to do next and uh
I was like I have no idea he's like well
no really like you know usually people
when they're you know they they come to
me it's because they already kind of
lined up something else I was like no
honestly I have no idea I just know that
I need to make some space and so that
part resonates with me and also the idea
of like you like when I look back now
and I'm like oh like before I sold our
company if I didn't if my company wasn't
going to be the next big thing I would
just shut it down literally just turn it
off take a zero on it and then I just
started looking around and I learned
this word Aqua higher in Silicon Valley
I was like oh people just sell failing
companies and then I learned like you
know the asset sale it's like oh you
could just sell the code and the assets
like wait who are these buyers and I
didn't even really understand what my
options were and so when you talk about
basically I could have refinanced I
could have just refinanced based on the
business assets took 90 of the value I
felt that same like stupidity later but
like that's life life is basically
looking back and being like I was such
an idiot and that's how I Mark years of
time not by like the calendar days but
by number of times I look back and say
God I was so dumb I didn't even
understand this I was sitting on
something I didn't really under I didn't
really know what I should now knowing
what I know now I know exactly what I
should have done and at that time I
didn't I wasn't even aware that I was
making a mistake well the difference is
like I think that we all us three
actually have done we're we are
tacticians so like I understand how to
grow [__] and I understand like you
build this page you do this thing uh you
write these words here's the customer
you talk to them whatever I think the
the with a gap you have to bridge is
becoming a uh from tactics to strategy
and I used to like make fun of all my
buddies who are in finance I'm like dude
you're just like an Excel monkey you
don't know anything like you're just
this stupid [__] hedge fund and maybe
it makes money but you don't know [__]
and then I realized like when they talk
about a debt and stuff I was like I'm
not gonna pay attention any of that
because I think that's stupid and then I
realized how it starts working and I'm
like oh my God that's like a strategy so
it's like that's the strategy and that
and I was like oh I used to like I'm
I've got good Vision I understand how
this [__] works and then I realized how
money worked a bit more with debt and
borrowing other people's money to do
this and like taking money off the table
and all these like terms that I kind of
heard about but I didn't exactly
understand I realized [__] if I'm gonna
be like really good at my job I I gotta
be good I gotta understand the tactics
you really also have to understand the
strategy which Alex it seems like you're
actually now now you get the strategy of
how money and business works not just
the tactics which the whole hundred
million dollar offer book which I really
think it's awesome that's mostly
tactical but the Strategic [__] is what
you're saying of like oh you can borrow
other people's money and to do this that
that's some big picture [__] yeah
without a personal guarantee so because
a lot of people like why do I did on the
business because I don't want to risk
that I was like you are not risking it
like the business is risking in it and
if you're willing to do a sale for X
it's like well you willing to do uh like
because the business is going to take
the risk on either way I mean depending
on the acquire but if you're selling a
private Equity like I know you have a
lot of a bigger Tech audience but I
probably have a bigger like uh like sir
like I would say everyday business
audience you know guys who have massive
Roofing businesses or you know a huge
chain of you know teeth whitening
Studios you hear me like just just those
types of businesses are the ones that
tend to to follow more of my stuff and
like that's usually going to be a
roll-up or a private equity acquirer for
the most part right maybe a strategic if
you like have another big teeth
whitening chain that wants to buy you
but like that's about it
um and
I I think I I resonate with what you
said Sam I always thought those guys
like I was like you don't even
understand business and I to a degree I
actually don't think they understand
business but they understand the macro
level of business and I think where you
get really dangerous is when you know
both
like you can because what they do they
almost purely inorganic growth they try
and staple [__] together that okay we
bought four companies that do you know
three million in ebitda and so now we
have problems we're gonna have some
Equity Arbitrage and we're gonna be able
to sell this thing Financial engineering
yeah saddle them up with that and then
it's just then it's just a math equation
like it doesn't even matter about
growing the businesses but it's like
what if you do that and you could also
triple all the businesses and it's like
that's when you create these like
breathtaking home runs and that's kind
of what I mean that's what we're trying
to do with acquisition and I don't
I don't have I don't have uh I don't
have a huge need for more money unless
it's a an enormous like there's nothing
I can do I'm I'm have you ever have you
ever heard Felix Dennis's uh like uh how
to be rich I think that's the name of
the book yeah
we're talking about that table a lot
like the comfortably poor you know
comfortably Rich then you get to like
rich rich you're super resonated with me
it's like I'm the I'm the the
comfortably rich
oh like not the Super Rich not the like
so uh like everybody here we can all
consume whatever we want so we can find
whatever planes we like you know you can
fly private you can stay in the nicest
hotels get the nicest airbnbs go out to
dinner every single night of the week at
the five-star restaurant at the Michelin
star
and you can do that for the rest of your
life like you your personal needs as a
human being are satisfied but I can't
buy that skyscraper right there
and I can't buy this huge company and so
what happens is like the things that you
want to buy change and so you create a
new deficit for the amount of wealth
that you want again this is just
assuming you like the game and so like I
like the game and so I just want to keep
playing it the the funny thing is that
what you actually like is just playing
the game and if you just said well I'm
rich enough then you'd have to stop
playing the game you really love and so
instead you start to come up with like
things you want that in actuality sound
a little bit silly it's like actually I
don't even think you want that
skyscraper or to buy that you know I
don't even think that's actually what
motivates you it's just that I I'm
actually Peak loving the game right now
and the game only works if you care
about the score and so you know it is
impossible to enjoy that you can't play
the game if you've said I've already
scored the maximum number of points then
the game becomes kind of silly and so
it's funny like this is with all of our
friends it's like well why are you doing
this don't you you kind of got enough
money man and it's like yeah but I don't
have enough enjoyment the enjoyment game
is infinite and the thing I enjoy the
most is playing this game and um you
know I'm so I'm going to continue
playing but in order to do so I have to
like construct these silly like dreams
that I I'm not even sure I really care
as much about as far as just playing the
game dude that was huge and um as a side
note it's like if you think there's
there's kind of like I feel like two
ways you can create a deficit right so
one is like you can create a financial
deficit by saying like I want this thing
it's cost a billion dollars and so I
need to go make a billion dollars
there's my deficit to where I am where I
want to go the other side is what I
would say like when you ask like what
are you like excited about because I
said like what are the worst Parts but
like I'll tell you what's what's good
right now is that we have finally
separated Mosey media which is basically
like my my Layla personal brand and like
the content we put out I would say the
books kind of fall under that like the
courses the books all the materials we
give out to
um to MOSI media and so what we
originally were saying we started
acquisition.com is that the mission was
to make real business knowledge
accessible to everyone like that was the
that was the mission of the company and
that is still very much the mission of
Mosey media what we realized is that
hold codes team so like RX Consultants
are are people who recruit Talent our
heads of sales we build out sales teams
or has marketing better marketing
departments and marketing functions our
head of customer success who build that
product in the client experience Etc
like those people didn't really resonate
with making business uh education
accessible to everyone like that wasn't
actually like what their mission was and
so we got really clear on what the
mission of acquisition.com is which is
in this kind of came organically so it's
like really exciting for me
um but one of the things I've always
envied about Elon is that like every
company he gets involved in basically
Saves the World they're like what like
he finds a way to tie the mission of
what he's doing to saving the world so
even Twitter he was like free
civilization needs free speech and it's
like boom I was like man how did he take
a a meme platform with tweets arrogant
dudes you know and turned it into a you
know free speech for civilization like
that's where I think a lot of his
Geniuses
um and so for us I was like what's that
saying and so we have the external gap
of like yeah I want to hit the billion
or whatever
um but I think the internal one is that
we want to build a company off of praise
and not punishment and so we have this
huge thing in terms of how we try to
build things is like you can punish
people or you can praise them and we
believe that you get more performance
out of Praise now you look at Goldman's
actually JP Morgan look at McKenzie look
at Ben you look at these massive
companies even some of these like huge
ones and it's a lot of people are like
man it's a toxic work environment it's
really hard blah blah and so those are
usually punishment driven cultures and
so we want to and so it's what's
happened is like by doing that that has
aligned all of our hold code team in
terms of how we want to build these
companies and the billion dollar Alex
Lark is basically irrelevant because
like to really win by their standards we
need to build something that's 10 or 50
or 100 billion you know what I mean and
that might take the rest of my lifetime
it'll probably happen after I die but if
we can do that then we can prove one
thesis which is like people want to work
and most environments are set up to
punish people and all you do is you
raise the bar of what it takes to not
get punished but what happens is people
turn out of work they burn out they hate
their jobs they hate their lives and I
think that there's a better way and
Layla and I are going to try and
dedicate the rest of our lives to trying
to prove that and so that is the mission
of acquisition.com and what we do with
the companies and we can show that that
it's not just like floofy stuff and I
think if it were just Layla it'd be a
woman driven thing to be like oh it's a
girl who's saying you should be nice to
people but I think I given how I look
how I talk I can probably deliver that
message
um and it may take the rest of my life
to do it but like I haven't felt like
[__] amped about anything in a long
time the last time I was this pumped was
when the mission of gym launch was to
take the gym industry from his knees to
his feet because the average gym owner
takes down 36 000 a year in personal
income
um and has like maxed out credit cards
and has like 18 days of cash on hand and
I was like I want to fix this and what
ended up happening is like I because I
wasn't emotionally mature enough
um I took enough licks from people
really close to me both clients and
employees
um that I just like I just needed put
distance like I had 17 different people
work for me try to start their version
of my business you know what I mean I
had uh clients trying to you know like
start their like because it was a it was
a business based on Consulting right it
was a Consulting business so like once
you had kind of the models you could in
theory trying to be with us now no one
has succeeded
um but it was enough that I was like
dude you were bankrupt and like
and like on the brink of divorce and you
used all the stuff and then like you
scaled to three locations and sold them
and now your family's financially set
off and like now you want to attack me
like it happens enough times to your
feet and then you kick me this is how I
get repaid for this that's how it felt
that's how it felt and so I wasn't I
like I think now I could handle it a lot
better but at the time I just like I
felt so disenfranchised I just felt hurt
honestly because I really poured my soul
into trying to fix the gym industry and
so when I felt that way we created space
and then it just became an asset we
owned and that's why I was open to
selling it
um but like I haven't felt like that
until now it's so funny you mentioned
the Elon big mission thing like this guy
he did it with Twitter too which was
really funny and then uh while he was
doing that deal news came out it's like
oh Elon Musk impregnates like this woman
who worked for him and he's like and he
was like
he's like overpopulation under
population we were at risk of population
collapse it's actually the biggest risk
of all and he's like I'm just doing my
part and I was like this guy yeah like
how did he get away with it he spun that
[__] like like he did his full like 540
on that thing spitting that to be like
actually
actually I was also saving the planet
with that one too
okay
it's like just like the male male
[__] like the abilities for some
some men to just absolutely [__]
their way out of everything and uh
elon's got that like he is the world he
is the world leader in that I think
there's a minute though like in terms of
like because even thinking if I wanted
to create a stronger narrative because
like I'm already amped about this
narrative but like again it's I think
there's there's power in reframing what
you do to be something that aligns with
Humanity because to be fair doesn't
matter what you do if like you if you
chunk up enough like people need food
right you want to feed Humanity like
like a lot like a lot of these things
that are necessary for civilization all
like trumped up enough like our pillars
of society yeah it it's all what story
you're telling yourself because then
you'll tell that story to others and if
that story serves you then then great I
mean I think I personally I think this
is the Silicon Valley like uh what like
PTSD or whatever where it's like anytime
I hear a mission statement I'm like just
shut the [__] up like tell the truth you
want to make money great you want your
own life value to increase and you
realize that in order for you to get
that value you had to create more value
in the world and so you identified some
people that needed something and you
provided that value in Spades whether
that was dentists need better software
or that's uh you know the world needs a
social network or we want to send
disappearing photos back and forth to
each other's phones like
um you know you hear Evan Spiegel like
you go look at the original landing page
it's of Snapchat or the emails that he
sent to the sororities and fraternities
where he's just like the landing page is
like two chicks in a white bikini like
kind of like do like taking like a
naughty selfie basically and then
there's a giant timer where like the the
the photos gonna disappear and same
thing when he's emailing the the frats
and sword he's telling me he's not
saying I'm trying to you know reinvent
the way that humans communicate actually
you know 75 of our brains is wired for
images not text and so I wanted to make
a messaging app that was image based and
that you know and then you hear him do
the pitch and he's like um you know for
too long images have only been used for
memories but I wanted to use images for
communication the way we originally did
with hieroglyphics and [__] it's like
bro it's okay that you thought this app
was fun and cool and like that it might
be a hit and it took off in like you
know these like schools and because
people wanted to get around you know
their teachers or parents being able to
see photos on their ephemeral like
that's okay and uh but they always do
this they always tie it back
now it's the d word it's democratized
access to private limos really those
were like and then of course what does
it become right as the marketing teams
get in there and the consultants get in
there they're like we're we're our
mission at Uber is to make
Transportation as readily available as
running water that's because that became
their mission statement it sounds
[__] yeah yeah yeah when at first it
was amazing
and literally the early stories of
anybody who knew Travis and Garrett at
Uber was like they'd be like dude check
this out
push a button while they're at the at
their like Michelin star dinner and be
like watch this car shows up and they're
like yeah that's right it's balling
right I could see where he's at on the
map like this is amazing this is my
private driver you know I summoned him
through my app and it's like there's a
there's always to me like the disconnect
between what I think the truth is which
is a little bit skeptical and jaded and
then like the revisionist history story
that like sounds really admirable and
Noble and like I personally have just
come down and I've landed on like I'm
okay with the truth I get the human
nature we're kind of just Primal animals
and it's okay you seek pleasure you
avoid pain you like status and you yeah
you don't want to follow status like
it's okay but Alex's Alex is uh like
Mission so like you know Alex maybe it
started as like the mission of our
company is to get your money and to put
it in our bank account
like like we're changing our bank
account one dollar at a time
I think you get our dollar like
it's like I because inevitably I imagine
it started with I just want to get rich
and do dope [__] and then it changed to
uh you know this pretty Grand thing of
changing work through instead of using
praise and when did that change I think
it's a yes and so Sean I'm like like the
bullshitometer ETC like I I
fullheartedly hear you on that and I
think that one is that the truth can
change and what I mean by that is
because it's not like we're not talking
about a fact we're talking about truth
of of why someone does something and so
like why someone does something can
change so like when I started gym Lodge
I've said this as many times like the
mission of gem launchers to not be broke
like that was the mission of gym launch
but what happened is after I saw the
lives that got transformed from it and I
was no longer broke the mission had to
change because I had accomplished that
mission so the mission had to get bigger
in order to continue to expand that
because that families relied on me
employees Etc customers and so it did
truly become to take its knees uh needs
to from Ace to the gym membership
foreign right and so like
acquisition.com started with the thing
that I was passionate about because the
only thing I was passionate about was
just spreading like good business like I
love talking about business it's like my
favorite thing in the whole world
picture about business I write books
about this I make course about business
my content about this like and then I do
business in the meantime like I [__]
love business and so that was the only
thing that I felt passionate about and
so that's what I made the mission about
but as we've walked the path realizing
that like the reason the businesses have
done really well for us is because of
the cultures that we create and we
believe that those cultures
um create better businesses and honestly
also better working environment like
generate really good bottom line but
also really great experiences for the
people who who work there and so like I
haven't been amped about it and so like
the truth of why I want to go there now
and now I see that a much bigger picture
than I did when we started it two or
three years ago
um I think that I think your reasons
evolve and so I think that it makes
sense that I think it's both honestly
personal goals he was like he had
transferred money from that person's
account to his to the degree that he
could buy whatever he wanted and so I
think you just think more about it and
you're like why do I want to do this
because you have to have a reason
otherwise you just you you go to a ball
of nothingness and so yeah well look I
mean I think the best way to actually
learn that um we were talking about the
last episode we talked about uh what's
the uh restaurant Panda Express guy yeah
and then and we were like
you know he he he just sells like orange
chicken like that's not exactly
inspiring but like he he he employs like
20 000 people and he like gives these
guys I think he we were talking about I
have my notes here he gives them all
like he pays a little bit for them to go
to Tony Robbins he gives them like the
Think and Grow Rich books and like all
these books and he's like yeah like the
whole chicken [__] like that's kind of
cool and all but like I'm actually like
taking an hourly wage worker and we're
trying to like Elevate them and so I'm
like oh I can get behind that I'm I'm in
on that and if you look at like a lot of
non-tech or non-silicon Valley companies
employ like 30 000 people and they're
like yeah you know we sell tires and
that's cool but I'm really just trying
to like we we create jobs and that's
very fascinating and that's really
exciting and that's cool it's better for
the economy or like you know some of
these like really boring brick and Morty
uh brick and mortar businesses I think
that's actually where you see a lot of
really cool missions or like um if you
I've read the uh have you read about the
Koch brothers
um you mean Coke like Coke Industries
yeah yeah yeah yeah Coke industry so
basically it started with the dad he was
like oil guy and then they use the
byproduct of creating oil to create all
types of plastics and whatever
and so now it's arguably it goes back
and forth of the biggest privately owned
company in America and he was like no
like my whole thing is like freedom for
people you know and I want to like teach
them that they have autonomy and like
through working here he's got a whole
book on his Management systems and he's
like more so what I'm inspired about is
like uh is like giving empowering people
and so anyway when I read about those
like older companies I actually think
that that's a bit more inspiring than
like some dork saying that he's changing
the world one like computer chip at time
when it's like uh I don't know like
that's not exactly inspiring you know
maybe it hasn't played out yet yeah yeah
yeah like if Bill Gates said he like
when he started was like I want to have
a computer and everyone's like okay and
then he did it and so I think I think
part of it is also like what Snapchat on
the timeline are we looking at but dude
I 100 agree with you like I love like
because basically it shifts from
internal to external like in the
beginning you do it for you obviously
you do it because you get you get praise
instead of punish like you have good
more good [__] you keep doing it but
once the thing that was good no longer
like the diminishing Return of the
pleasure of more money isn't there
anymore then you have to find a new you
find a new goal like you said and then
anything also coincides with other
people being motivated by not making
Alex rich but by proving a point that we
can create companies that reward instead
of punish and actually have better
returns
like I'm Juiced and like we haven't
proved it yet that's fine we haven't
proves it yet we will I want to ask you
two two questions
the first is around people you admire so
we talked about the Panda Express guy on
our just our own last episode because we
were featuring it was like crazy Rich
Asians basically was the thought of the
episode and then uh and it turns out he
lives near you or whatever like you know
you're both in Vegas
um who are some people that you admire
so um I always find this interesting to
hear
who kind of like stands out and why uh
for for different folks so who are some
people that you admire either past or
present you know people that you've met
um because I know that this kind of like
getting famous on YouTube thing opens up
a bunch of doors you meet a bunch of
cool people that like you otherwise you
expand your circle of people you you get
to know
um through this stuff so who are some
people you admire well I definitely
admire Andrew Patron uh from Panda
Express because they're a married couple
who built this whole thing and they
didn't they never took out outside money
and they've owned the whole thing
privately they have 2 600 locations they
did 3.7 billion a year with 27 net
margins and they take 935 million a year
in personal income and I think that's
only possible because they have created
a new vision for what they wanted the
company to be about which is about their
employees
um I am inspired by Warren Buffett yeah
I mean I mean I I am because of the
long-term mentality he has and he built
Berkshire Hathaway and
in some ways I feel like he built it
he's like a beautiful life story of like
just believing in the power of
compounding and patience and like that's
what I feel like his virtues are that
he's demonstrated and rational decision
making
um I would say that for us it's like if
we can build something like that but
just with our own our own spin our own
zest which is around praise that
punishment building companies that like
we can win by their scoreboard but we do
it our way
um so that's that the Warren angle and
um I mean I admire Elon a lot
um a ton you know just like what we were
talking about earlier like his ability
to see vision and connect to a larger
Mission he's seen he's been able to
masterfully do that every single company
he's been a part of
um and his track record's incredibly
[__] impressive
um and he just continues to like defy
the laws of like what seems to be like
normal or possible over and over and
over again and so I think just like how
he just like stares into the abyss and
says like let's do it I think that's
something that I really really admire
um he obviously has flaws like all of us
do but I think he also has been really
good about like owning his flaws
um and being public about that he's just
a human and I think he may create a new
model for how big public CEOs rod and
maybe that you know maybe were in the
beginning of of That World
um
and uh
I think on the totally other side of the
coin I think I admire what like Mr Beast
has done from a personal branding
perspective
um I've been able to get to know him
really well
um and uh
and Jim's Jim thinks really big and uh
has a tremendous work ethic and I think
seeing the merger like seeing where all
these things are like Elon has been able
to build a personal brand and you know
in a lot of ways like if you're a fan of
Elon you want to buy all of the things
he just happens to have enormous
monetization vehicles
um and to your point Sam about like how
they use like yeah sure we make tires
yeah sure we sell orange chicken
um like in a lot of ways I see like all
the companies we have in acquisition.com
is like yeah of course we transact we
build businesses but like the reason we
do it is this and I think that's
um really dope and so that's that's like
those are probably the like if you were
to sort of mix like what are the things
that I'm drawing inspiration from at
current it's a and if you look at what
we're doing it probably would make sense
to see all three of those as the three
biggest kind of influencers you got like
Mr Beast on personal brand side here
you've got Warren Buffett on the
investment side and then Elon from like
the big vision and I feel like those
three things are probably where I draw
the most inspiration from in terms of
like our day-to-day and what we're
trying to do
what's interesting about you is that
you're pretty good at
you're very catchy so like the whole
knees to feet thing is is pretty awesome
um and then uh what was the line for
your current company it was uh reward
versus punish yeah thanks you're pretty
yeah everyone we would have beat him we
would beat him at their game and we
wouldn't do it our way well you said we
want to beat them on we want to use
their scoreboard but do it our way so
you've got you're quite lyrical
um you've also done a few there's like
actually a handful of things that you've
talked about very uh like casually that
I've caught on to that I really like so
for example
you say uh you say dessert what do you
say dessert every day never skip dessert
never skip dessert and then you also
because your whole like dieting thing is
you eat all of your protein earlier on
and then you're like all right now I
have uh fat and carbs I we can go big on
those uh like you've done like a few
things outside of business I find like
almost more impressive or I actually use
on my daily life more so than your
business stuff which I actually found is
pretty funny uh you also have I don't
know if you've seen the Sean but if you
Google like there's this like 23 year
old Alex who does a thing where he's
like I'm gonna do a bulk over the next
like eight weeks and he has like before
during and after photos and like that
stuff I look at significantly more than
a lot of your business stuff I find that
some of your Fitness uh and diet stuff
like more interesting applicable in my
day-to-day life than the business stuff
um
a living for like I like I joked about
it in the comments both I was like
people like admire are like my way of
thinking about things in business and I
was like
for a decade I did that with Fitness I
just don't talk about it because
everyone feels entitled to opinion
because they have a buy
and I just and I hate I hate getting
into the they're like what about salt
I'm like dude just [__] off like just
like you know like I have so little
patience works I'm like look at you
and like if you were more in shape
and by the way no one who's been more in
shape than me has ever criticized any of
the content favorite
just like people who are wealthier than
you never say [__] about business advice
like about you I'd be like no one ahead
of you ever said something
well the cool thing about it is like I I
use the fitness analogy a ton of
business because I'm like well it's hard
but it's simple and that if you lift
this much weight and eat like this for a
year you're not necessarily going to
look like Arnold or be lean or whatever
but you're gonna be pretty good or
better than where you are now and you
just got to do it for like two years and
you gotta like be fairly strict about it
um so like that's why the carryover uh
is quite fun watching you do both of
those things yeah I appreciate it yeah I
mean simple not easy I feel like it's
the it's a [__] theme of so many
things like Fitness Nutrition marriage
business like simple to do or simple
simple to understand conceptually very
hard to do what's the uh simple not easy
for marriage I mean I think it's it's
reward more than you punish I mean it
actually comes down to that so like okay
if I want my wife to scratch my back
more I have to wait until she scratches
my back of her own volition and then I
have to reward him immediately and then
she will want reward more and so she
will do it again uh and then in our
reward again and reward again very
pavlovian of you well yeah I mean I
think we're all though you know what I
mean fundamentally there's three things
you can do when anyone does anything
around you is that you can punish them
for doing it you can ignore that they
did it or you can Praise Him for doing
it I've ever heard um the Tony Robbins
like
I forget what he calls it but it's like
the four uh the four styles of being in
a relationship he says something like
this I don't know have you heard this
thing it's like um the first one uh let
me see if I can remember it after my
head so basically he goes uh you know
first one's like a baby it's like uh I
need love and I don't have to give
anything to you so it's just like I cry
you give and that's it like uh you
better be happy with that Arrangement so
that's like one relationship you can
have one style of relationship you can
have and obviously like doesn't work out
very well once you're an adult
um you can't just cry expect to be given
everything you want and then not have to
do anything in return
baby love so that's baby love
then he has uh the next one which is
basically Tit for Tat so it's uh this is
where almost everybody falls into so
this is probably going to sound familiar
at least to like to an extent and it's
probably the root of all problems in
relationships it's Tit for Tat which is
you measure what you get and then you
give based on that uh when you're when
you're given a lot you give a lot but
then as soon as somebody breaks the
cycle and they short you consciously or
unconsciously they they don't do what
you what you wanted
um you also withdraw or pull back some
amount of giving and then they
reciprocate uh give they also measure
and pull back and both sides do that you
end up with a sort of a race to the
bottom and so that's Tit for Tat and
that's where most people stand and they
it's just a cycle that resets over and
over again
um the next one is unconditional love
which is basically I give regardless of
what you give back I give because that's
who I am uh I give because that's how I
how that's how I want to roll in my
relationship and I control what I
control and uh obviously that's way
better and like to me that's the simple
not easy in of being in a relationship
is just go go unconditional mode rather
than Tit for Tat
um and then he has like some Higher One
which is monk monk love or something
like that he calls it where it's
spiritual love it's like I love you even
though you hate me uh like a monk can be
like I I I pray for and love even my
enemies and those trying to hurt me and
he's like you know nobody gets there but
like that's aspirately what you could
what you could get to as well is like
you know the love like a monk who loves
even their enemies
um and those who try to cause harm and
so that those are the the four levels of
love I remembered Alex do you ever so
like I saw this video of you the other
day and now everyone's like giving you a
hard time or they're just teasing you in
a good way about like your outfit
because you wear the same clothing all
the time so you made a funny video about
it and you go instead of just saying oh
comfortable you go
dude I'm just more Darwin than them
these shorts you want to go work out I
can go work out you want to go to
waterproof yeah that's what he said he
goes you want to go swimming these are
waterproof you want to go uh out to a
restaurant these look just good enough
that I can go and do that I can do
anyway I can do anything I'm darwinian
you're not I win you lose I bought the
shoes you invention because you you were
like these sandals these are the perfect
sandal for working out running through
you know like walking through rain
climbing a hill or like being at the
office and in the comments everyone's
like yo what's the sandal what's the
Sand where's the affiliate link we can't
find it and then some dude like 50
comments down it's like dude that's what
it's this brand uh the The Nightshade
color of this all right respect to this
guy for finding it I'm gonna go buy this
thing
dude but dude do you ever like does your
mom and dad are like hey quit being such
a douche and just wear what we bought
you because to be nice like at what
point do you like are you like this
makes sense for me and also like it's
good to the brand
um versus like live a little and like
let's just [__] around do you know what
I mean um yeah like the good for the
brand is is actually not like really a
thought when it comes to it like I
believe that like brand comes as a
result of rather than like conscious you
don't mean like like people like so
wouldn't you think of never skipped
dessert I was like I was making fun of
Fitness people because my original
audience was Fitness people who obsessed
about like not eating cookies and I was
like [__] off yeah I mean like eat
dessert you know what I mean but do it
in a way that you solve a six-pack all
the time so that was why I never skipped
it there's always like never Skip Leg
Day never skip Monday I was like
um like the Cavs thing is because like I
genuinely have started training I
started I started every training session
since since a girl told me that she
thought that my calves weren't big uh
it's been like 12 years 14 years that
I've TR I start every session with
calves
um and so like my calves have grown a
lot and so everyone's like oh Jeanette
like my calves were sticks and I'd train
the [__] out so like is it part of my
brand yeah because it's in some ways
like it's true Lindsay yeah yeah Lindsay
14 years of fuel you gave me and it's
the the outfit thing is actually because
my it's my content team that wanted to
make content about it because they're
like dude you're [__] Maniac with
this like I feel like people should know
this because everyone who knows you like
in person knows that like like when they
walked in for like almost a year and a
half there was stacks of shoe boxes and
I would wear
different shoes for a day an hour a day
a week they kind of graduated to like if
they're good enough or I can walk around
the apartment then I'll walk around for
their day if I can walk around with him
for a week and I still like them and
most of them never got there so I have a
few finalists that got to that point but
like I think I just like obsess about
making things better same things like if
I do end up doing a you know if there is
a good enough company that does no
strips like I'm going to iterate the
product a bunch of times until I think
it's absolutely Untouchable and then
I'll say this is the one I use and I can
say that I say that with confidence
because I I did the the work on it for
me I she I just hate having to change
like I don't know what it is it's like
it means that I started my day like not
thinking about what I was going to do so
I was like okay well if I can create a
setup or a uniform for myself that I can
be in the most environments so for me
I'm really never in less than 40 degree
weather like ever because I usually tend
to be in warmer spots of the country in
general uh and so like this this outfit
goes 40 to 120 degrees and so and I can
go to the gym I'm go to the pool I can
walk for hours I can walk all day I can
go to a nice restaurant I can do all
those things because if they need it but
that's crazy because your wife who I've
seen she dresses lovely she like it's
it's fashionable so her hair always
looks nice you know what I mean like I
said it goes 40 to 120 like a like a car
goes zero to sixteen
like this flannel this Jagger right here
this thing goes 40 to 120. once once
it's a once it's below 40 I get Cults I
have to put pants
um but like up until then I'm pretty
much good within that range and so like
I can I can button think like this thing
can go full full sleeves and like I'm
like that's when I'm in like mass cold
mode or if I go to a restaurant there
are fire safes I can have that right but
otherwise
um you know like I'm in Beater mode like
we go to the gym you know we go to the
pool we go to the beach we go wherever
I'm gonna be in Beater mode you know
what I mean and this is the latest
before I tried
yeah
like a car yeah well my whole outfit has
sports mode people are like proxious
more like my whole outfit has sports
mode and comfort mode and weather mode
and I can I can do that and so anyway I
mean like I I enjoy I enjoyed finding
each of these things almost as much as I
enjoy wearing them and I and I every
morning and this is true like every
morning when I put this on I get like a
little a little boost where I'm like I
know that I've picked every single one
of these pieces out and I have no doubt
that this is the best thing for me
like for my day and so like I know that
the brand of white Beaver that I have on
right now I tried 40 or 50 other brands
on and I want I knew this one sat where
I wanted to sit it wasn't too thick on
the shoulder or too thin it didn't drop
into some string on the back some people
like that I didn't want that
um like beaters themselves are thinner
than tank tops they're ribs so that they
fit right I think even like if you've
seen those Under Armor tank tops or
those like shrink wrap ones like they
don't look good like I think they look
synthetic and for me I think they look
like kind of synthetic like I don't like
it I like cotton better
um and so like there's just a number of
iterations like if I talked about the
shoe I could tell you a zillion things
that I looked at like I mean I just I
have like an Excel sheet that like I was
realized like dude
I thought you would have I have a few
friends like that I'm not as extreme but
I like buying and testing like a ton of
stuff
Sean was uh ordered like 20 of the same
shirts what products this is actually
interesting this I don't think this is
like too inside baseball but what
products and brands do obsess with and
love like uh in your daily life well um
I won't say them because I'm in talks
with like Hassan
uh to try and figure something out
um but I I will I will caveat that with
I think that in general for people like
my life might be different than theirs
and I think just being delivered like so
many people just like sleep walking
through life that like they're always
sitting there with their pants that just
don't fit just right or always don't
have this thing like a lot of stuff I
modify so like I might like my gym bag
like there's a video about my gym bag
like I tried out a bunch of different
bags and I finally found a bag that I
liked and then I modified the [__] out
of it and like that bag now every time I
go into a gym people are like dude that
bag's awesome I was like I know because
I made it for this function and it's
great and I love it it's really good you
know so I think it's more just like
finding that like whatever your 40 to
120 is because maybe you live in
Michigan and it's always cold it's like
we have a different standard standard
where what shorts are are they I thought
you used to wear just Jordans I used to
make fun of you for wearing I used to
wear Jordans but George did yeah so I'll
tell you I used to wear Jordans because
they were more comfortable and I could
do more casual settings with them right
they're like always showing up in like
athletic shorts yeah we just it just it
looked it looked like almost too casual
I think
um and a lot of restaurants are like no
athletic wear and so I was like okay
well that's annoying and so then it went
through this whole thing where I had to
find like the best short and then while
I was doing that like the ones that I
have have back hooks on them so that if
I can hang them too dry I've got an
iPhone pocket in there that's built in
so like because I hate having to sit and
then you take it out of your pocket yeah
every time like it's such a pain like
well there should be a pocket for this
everyone has one right and there's like
a little place that I could like an iPad
iPad pencil in my shorts because I use
my iPad a lot
um like I've got cargo on the other side
and uh these are stretchy but not too
stretchy but they're stretching with
Freight you hauling in there buddy what
do you got what type of what do you
think the cargo gummy bears no a lot of
times it's mic packs so a lot of times
it's mic packs because we're getting
like right now mic packs in my cargo
pocket
um but like I could fit a water bottle
in here if I need it
um Uber or a hotel Key like Hotel keys
there whenever we're traveling uh or I
use my Nicorette because I actually
Nicorette so I'll have Nick around my
pocket if I go on a podcast so I just
I'd like always have the stuff that I I
need there you know well the best the
best way possible man this is these are
my favorite kinds of PODS when you you
find out you know it's like I want to
see your weird uh that's when I know you
until I see your weird I don't actually
know you I feel this this is my personal
my personal thing and uh I'm glad we
went down this rabbit hole because we
got to see your weird it's funny because
later right now Maya actually I'm not
going to show you the brand but
um
I've got this backpack here right and
this backpack
I wore um
I can wear it like when we travel I can
wear it everywhere and it has everything
that I use to travel and I can travel
for for four weeks
because all I have to pack is three
pairs of shorts that are identical that
are multi everything and then I just
have an amount of tanks that is whatever
the laundry cycle of the trip is and
that's it and I could put one flannel on
top and I'm I'm good like and I don't
even have to use the expansion part of
that backpack which I have options if I
need it uh and so like and it has a cool
front thing for all my wires that's flat
so it doesn't take up space like there's
just a lot of like when I went through a
zillion different bags to find that I
went through a zillion different bags to
find the gym bag but like no whenever I
pick it up I'm like this is the best
back to the job
what of the best uh where you spend
money for you personally like not like a
business investment that uh you know
you're you think it's a great Roi or you
get a bunch of joy out of it or it's
like uh dope for you
um that is let's say not your content
team and not like something that's
directly in the business yeah I mean I
would say jsx is is wonderful since it's
in the southwest so it's a uh it's like
summer private flying
oh it's great I mean it gives you so
like I the only reason we fight private
is because it saves it's the only reason
we do it like and you a lot less hassle
but jsx allows you all the benefits of
private flying this it's like a [__]
jsx plug but it's really good
um and the tickets like 300 bucks when
it would normally be like 50. so if you
want to fly jsx from Vegas to Salt Lake
or Vegas to Scottsdale or Vegas to to La
um it's 300 bucks it's nothing right and
you really you walk up to the plane you
get on the plane and then you walk off
the plane like that's it you know I mean
like it's it's just like private there's
just a few other people there and
private flying in my opinion has the
most benefit for the shortest travels
and the least benefit for the long
travels because like long travels you
want to fly as high as possible as fast
as possible the bigger you know the
bigger the plane the better and um and
by percentage of the trip you know the
the going through security and dealing
with the hassle if you have a five and a
half hour flight
five and a half hours versus like seven
hours of Transit
does it you like the day's fruit like
it's kind of like it doesn't materially
change a lot but on a short travel where
you're going like sub I would say sub
two hours
like you can you can double the length
of the trip or triple the length of the
trip I got in Reverse cut it in half or
by a third by flying private and so
that's where I feel like you get the the
highest marginal benefit it's also the
cheapest uh private flight to the
shortest ones because it's by hour so
that's kind of like when we when we when
we go back and forth and uh usually the
only times will fly private is if we
can't get a direct uh jsx play we'll
wrap up in a second here but last time
you were here Sean asked uh a question
about your portfolio
um and I want to follow up on it what's
your portfolio looking like in terms of
like your
um both your private Investments as well
as like what are you doing with your
money are you keeping it in equities
bonds cash I think last time you were
super heavy cash if I remember correctly
or Alternatives yeah that's what it was
it was treasuries you're like I'm almost
entirely treasuries what's it what's it
looking right now in terms of like a if
you can do like a pie chart and
percentages probably still half
treasuries except now they're a lot
better than before
yeah they're probably half treasuries
probably the quarter in just like
indexes
um
and the other quarter is in private
companies so pretty simple yeah probably
not by value and over time that that
treasury part is going to continue to
decline as we do more and more deals
um yeah I still think that like I mean I
don't know what the future looks like so
I like I I tend to like having lots of
cash like I feel good I never want to
not be able to do a deal that's gonna
10x because I don't have cash like that
like the the cost of missing the 10x is
well worth the quote inflation that I'm
suffering for the difference between the
treasury yield and the inflation cost
well thank you for uh coming out again
you um if you go to our YouTube page my
first million you're actually like the I
don't know what they call that video but
you're like our main page video for a
while
yeah and it's like a quote of like I've
come to the conclusion that I just like
to work and I don't like when people ask
me why am I working all the time or
something like that but uh thanks for
doing this again and uh uh we really
appreciate it no I mean thank you guys
for having me on and thank you to the
audience for maybe making requests to
have me back on so I I appreciate it and
it means a lot to me so uh thank you
guys for just being awesome host in
general
awesome well that's the pod
[Music]
foreign